what would you expect from the budget
well good morning Kate I think we're
going to get some pretty bad economic
news for the office for Budget
responsibility not just bad news on the
likes of energy bills and high inflation
but the economy growing very slowly
possibly ending this Parliament as weak
as it began it's much weaker than we
were previously expecting and actually
unemployment to rise which is the
opposite of what we've been seeing in
the recent past so pretty Grim economic
Outlook in the face of that being told
that yes you'll get some energy support
in the short term but in the longer term
it's tax Rises and spending cuts what
does that mean for many people who are
basically on the brink of not being able
to pay their mortgages
well on the tax Rises will probably be
largely takeaways from Midland richer
households because those are the people
that bear most of the burden of income
taxes and capital gains taxes which are
the ones that are likely to increase but
obviously reductions in public services
that those on low incomes rely on most
everyone relies on them but those are
low incomes rely on them most will be
felt most at the bottom and obviously
Rising energy bills and in particularly
look at what's happening to food prices
right now energy and food obviously key
Essentials we all need to buy they make
up a bigger basket of consumption for
lower income households and it's those
households who are seeing the highest
inflation rate right now and finding the
cost of living crisis the hardest to
deal with and what's your view on the um
Energy bill help that had been promised
by a previous chance so it looks as
though that is you know perhaps going to
change significantly
well we'll see what the chancellor says
later this morning but I think what
we're going to get is a combination of
the repeat of the direct payments to the
to vulnerable households pensioners
those the disability and those on Lower
incomes that Rishi sunak announced back
in May that will get repeated for
another year and then on top of that
they'll keep Liz truss's energy price
guarantee but have it for at a higher
level so allow energy bills to rise the
average Energy bill to around 3 000
pounds rather than the current 2500
level that will be for everybody
remember three thousand pounds compares
to an average Energy bill before this
crisis of around
1100 pounds so these are really big
increases and then as I say targeted
help for some households those are those
that do receive that help will get you
know significant amounts maybe a
thousand pounds uh support but obviously
Lots won't including actually some of
the poorest households because remember
a four in ten of the poorest households
aren't on means tested benefits and they
won't receive those targeted payments
what do you want me to say about
pensions I mean when we think about
pensioners we think about some that you
know are struggling and to hit their
home living in just one room and but not
all pensioners are like that
no I mean you know pensioners like
everybody have a big variety pension
inequality of income amongst pensioners
has been rising significantly over
recent decades as a richer Boomer cohort
ages into and towards retirement so you
do have a very big diversity the good
news is that average pensioner incomes
have been growing and actually catching
up with the rest of the population over
the course of the last few decades the
typical pensioner is now about the same
income as the typical working age
household despite having lower costs but
then the bad news is because pensioners
in lots of cases are now homeowners
intend to have larger homes than younger
households these days particularly per
person their houses are actually harder
to heat they're often less energy
efficient homes too so the direct effect
of energy bills on pensioners is also
worse for them than it is for lots of
other younger populations but overall
there's been good news on the pensioner
front in recent decades talk to me about
what Andrew Bailey said yesterday
governor of the bank of England he said
the UK is in a far worse position than
the EU to and the US after covid
well I mean he was specifically talking
about what's happened to our GDP the
size of our economy since the pandemic
and he's right to say that we're the
only economy in the G7 that hasn't
recovered to the size it was before the
pandemic struck and that should be a
really serious worry particularly
because it comes on the back of quite
slow growth before the pandemic remember
no business investment growth since 2016
and low wage growth even going back
until the financial crisis remember we
went into the pandemic with the same
level of wages we had going into the
financial crisis so this really has been
a terrible 15 years almost of economic
performance for the country some bright
spots like on employment but overall on
GDP on productivity on our wages it's
been a disaster
okay great to see you thanks for
checking the time thanks